at home you don't want the paler
higher-temperature line of fluorescent
bulbs crushing your soul save that kind
of thing for the office the hue wireless
system lets you control the color and
brightness of up to 50 bulbs at a time
with a simple app get a nice slow
brightening for an easy wakeup or just
set the lights up to turn on and off so
your house can pretend you're home when
you're really off gallivanting maybe you
want the kitchen to be that same
energizing fuzzy glow of a typical
fluorescent in the dining room to be
more hospitable or just change colors
play with the system just right and you
can replicate the lighting and
photographs in a real room you might
even be able to induce a genuine light
bulb moments